dis-moi biennale est ce que tu seras me
raconter l'histoire de noël
oui ouais c'est un décembre quand il
neige
et puis vient un jour qui vient où on
prépare mon petit soulier
nous on attend notre famille
l'entrée de retard hommage
et après on va devant la cheminée on
voit tous les jouets c'est seulement ça
noël c'est aussi une grande fête la fête
de quoi fait du père noël
[Musique]
son anniversaire c'est la fête des
enfants et comme les parrains fête des
pères la fête des mères alors non aviens
droit à une petite fanfare
c'est plutôt une fête pour les parents
pour les enfants pour l'école mais pour
toute la famille quand même pour le
chien je m'accuse en commun science
ils sont dès le jour de noël oui raphaël
et et les cadeaux de noël qui fait le
plus plaisir à moi ces boutons moto mais
qu'elle a battu j'ai 2 1 tu pourrais
monter sur une moto
ouais j'ai déjà monté que les cadeaux
que tu aurais recevoir christine à
l'occasion de noël des habits pourquoi
pas de jouets magiques moins ce que
j'aimerais le plus pur cadeau de noël
certains vêtus frère un petit frère tu
ne vas pas que des g en vérité le jeu
noël c'est d'abord il faut d'abord aller
à la messe de minuit et après une fois
que la messe de minuit elle et elle est
terminée c'est bien il faut aller faire
le grand festin la fin du repas il ya
les treize desserts c'est s'aider fruits
alors autrement g13 fruits et l écho kae
on l'aimé pour savoir combien mois à
noël ici est ce que toi tu fais quelque
chose de particulier ce que tu manges
quelque chose de bon aussi j'suis pas
que tu es ma mère m'a même fait la fête
du carême
sefyu couscous pas la donne et tout le
truc il ya là des ddh alliés qui font ça
mais il nous faut un sens à nouveau
comme s'ils savent pas qu'ils sont pas
chrétiens ils savent pas qu'ils sont qui
peuvent pas être chrétien celui-ci fasse
assez pour manger un peu pour se gaver
le genre de nouvelle
qu'est ce que tu fais le jour de noël
oui clos fait la croche et l'échappée
qu'est ce que c'est la crèche
accrocheuse voyage est intervenu suite
aux jets à voler un ennemi des santons
qu'est ce que ces descentes ont cherché
des petits personnages et on les
fabrique ou convenir
quels sont les différents personnages
pour mot les santons ya des chasseurs
yam du pêcheur ya des points sony
j'aime des enfin y'a jésus qui avait
aussi corps a dit jeudi qu'elle est leur
avis leur vie parce que ça
ravi c'est monsieur qui auront les
meuniers qui est bras comment faut-il
bon montre moi d'être comme ça et
pourquoi ce que tient ses bras en l'air
c'est pas leur avis c'est lui qui
annonçait la naissance de jésus
les nouveaux de ce personnage c'est une
ferme on vient de dames jésus avec eux
une vache heenan avec marie et joseph
et à quoi sert la manche est licencié de
l'air chaud ça le réchauffé y a pas les
moyens de se réchauffer non il y avait
le feu mais n'avait pas d'amis
[Musique]